this
is star talk cosmic queries
a special edition on vaccines
my co-host paul mercurio are you ready
for this one i
i feel sick already you feel sick
already
so so you're ready for this one i think
go ahead
yeah i'll go ahead and of course neither
of us have any expertise in this at all
other than reading about it in the
papers so we we we
we found one of the best if not the best
at this
dr paul offit paul welcome to star talk
thank you thanks for asking me yeah so i
looked at your your pedigree here
director of the vaccine education center
and
professor of pediatrics in the division
of infectious disease
at the children's hospital of
philadelphia so
you're the man for this for this episode
i'm not exaggerating here correct i
think i'm a-man
[Laughter]
the man but before we get to our
abundant
questions that have been submitted to us
by our fan base on all manner of our
social media platforms um i just i have
some just basic questions about what
we're all going through
in this pandemic why was i so naive to
think
that 100 years ago we had the the flu
pandemic oh that was a hundred years ago
this is the 21st century that can't
happen we have other issues but not that
what what is going on what why was
why why did this even happen at all in
what we are thinking of as modern times
so um this is essentially a bat
coronavirus that has adapted itself
to growth in humans this happens
fairly frequently i mean we saw there
was sars
one that happened in 2002 that was
followed a few years later by
years which came out of the first one
came out of asia the second one out of
the middle east
so these are we're constantly in
association with other animals and then
we sort of share our viruses and one
adapts to one or the other
most of the infections of people
actually originally started an
animal so it's not unusual we've had
warnings for this we just weren't
ready for this one so if we if we if we
focus on
vaccines for for this if you know this
is
in the works at all times
is is there a hope that
we can be out ahead of these things
instead of running up behind them
i think it's it's hard to to predict
exactly how it's going to happen
that it's going to happen is clear when
it's going to happen is exactly what the
virus is going to look like we don't
know but once we identified and this
this was i think the tragedy of this
when
this fire started to sweep across gujan
and and cause people to suffer and be
hospitalized and die and they were
building
hospital after hospital and wuhan trying
to handle all this
we should have known about that early
earlier the world should have known
about that earlier we shouldn't have
had to rely on a whistleblower to tell
us that this was going to happen a
whistleblower that ultimately died
we should have had that virus in hand
back in november and and
all the the world then should have been
working on a vaccine way back then but
so we there was a late start with this
so
uh and of course you're in the middle of
i mean i get some of it because it's
anti-science when i see people
saying i'm not gonna do a vaccine i
think they're dangerous you know they're
making their own decisions
you know in a free country we encourage
people to
to be independent and you know there's
this conflict of messaging
to say you live in a free country and i
have freedom of choice
but now you're saying i don't have
freedom of choice even if i don't want
your vaccine so
you're in the middle of that how does
how do you deal with this
well it plays out at many levels i mean
this notion that uh
that i don't want to wear a mask i i
it's my right it's my freedom as an
individual in this country
because it's in the constitution paul
you saw that right yes it's uh
they were using mass made out of uh
cowhide at the time they were very
sweaty but uh
by the way i just wanted to interject i
have covert i'm recovering from it
and i got it because i was around people
that refused to wear masks and some
thought it was a hoax
and my concern is when the vaccine comes
out
that they're talking about you know hurt
immunity the same people they're going
to declare declaring their right not to
wear a mask
might declare right not to take a
vaccine
and this is just going to be a bigger
problem you know because i think what
we're all missing is it's right
plus social responsibility to your
fellow man
right so how do you how do you how do
you walk that line or is it aligned to
what
well it's not to me this is not a line
at all it's it's not your right to catch
and transmit a potentially fatal
infection
any more than it's your right to deny
your child a potentially life-saving
vaccine sorry i mean
any more than it's your right to run a
stop sign just because you feel like it
i mean you do have a responsibility to
society and this is an example of that
it really it's really hard to watch
people say i'm not going to wear a match
because it's about my matter of mind
it doesn't just affect you it affects
people who come in contact with you
just uh i got it i got it and my son got
it
and his girlfriend got it for that
reason i had someone come up to me and
say take your mask off this is in
florida
this whole thing's a hoax yeah and paul
that's why
we shipped we shipped paul mccurry to
the moon so he's broadcasting to us yes
i'm in a giant i'm in a giant plexiglas
box actually
you can't see it it's a little hab
module yeah exactly
so if uh so uh dr offit if you
one of your roles is education a vaccine
education it's in your title
so what have you seen to be the greatest
challenge
at this well to make a vaccine quickly
i think it's actually remarkable how
quickly it's going to be made you know
the the
average length of time it takes to make
a vaccine is 15 to 20 years
i was fortunate enough to work with the
team at children's hospital philadelphia
that created the strains that became the
rotavirus vaccine that was a 26-year
effort
it's amazing that we're going to make a
vaccine in a year and a half and we are
we just got the virus really in january
there will likely be a vaccine by no
later than the middle of next year
i want it now hey i just got the russia
vaccine and
it's fine there's no problem at all
and you speak russian overnight so
paul mccurry both paul um let's go to
the
questions and see what people have all
righty you have patreon ones on top
these are uh as you can tell all patreon
wow okay let's do it uh so this is eli
patreon i've heard that people have
become infected with cobit twice how is
this possible
unless the virus has mutated please
enlighten me and thank you
yeah excellent all right so um
if you're going to make a vaccine
successfully the most important thing
is to watch what happens with natural
infection you want natural infection to
protect against disease associated with
re-exposure that doesn't have to
completely protect
you just wanted to protect against
moderate to severe disease which
apparently is what this virus does so if
you're infected with this virus you can
get still get infected again
you can still get asymptomatically
infected or mildly symptomatically
infected
what you haven't seen with the exception
of one person i've read about you
haven't seen people get moderate to
severe disease
and then say five six eight months go by
and then they get moderate to severe
disease again which then suggests
the natural infection doesn't protect
against these which means you're going
to have a hard time making a vaccine
that's so so what's happening is is what
you would expect to happen
the virus it's not because the virus
mutates it's because this particular
type of virus
coronavirus induces protection that is
short-lived meaning likely to last years
but not decades
and incomplete meaning protection
against moderate to severe disease
but not all forms of reinfection so
why can't you go in to everybody who's
been affected find their antibodies
and isn't that the anti-coronavirus
magic potion why does it require this
i know it's a naive question but if you
have all of these people that have
achieved natural immunity
go in there and like clone whatever the
antibodies
and then stick that in into other
people's bodies is or is that what
fighting a vaccine is well so advantage
of that the advantage of a vaccine
is that then you're you instruct your
body to be able to make the antibodies
that you need when you confront the
virus which is a lot
less expensive way to do it and also if
you're going to take the so-called
convalescent plasma
antibodies from people who've been
convalescing from infection who've
survived infection you would have to
give it really prophylactically
preventively
it really wouldn't work to treat unless
you gave it
really just just even before one had
symptoms it's true of all all sorts of
antibody preparations
they don't work really once you've
already started to develop symptoms
so that whole thing with convalescent
plasma and donald trump
standing up there and saying how this
was going to be a major breakthrough you
know convalescent pilot first of all
i was on a conference call with some nih
researchers and one of them said yeah
major breakthrough
maybe it'll win the nobel prize in 1890
i mean
and nih you mentioned that that's the
natural institutes of health yes right
can i so if you know the idea is to
create these antigens
uh uh to combat these pathogens and
corona this
this virus is in the family of
coronaviruses
uh why can't we quickly and i know you
said it's on a
fast track compare comparatively
speaking but why can't
an easy adaptation of a vaccine we're
already using for a
coronavirus be used here what's going on
in the body
so there is no other coronavirus vaccine
there's four strains of human coronary
virus that circulate every year
listen if you're going to contradict me
with all your knowledge
i don't need this i got coronavirus
buddy i'm
sick go ahead sorry sorry
that was the cove at speaking that
wasn't me now you know why we put them
on the moon
[Laughter]
right so as you know there are four
strains of human core other viruses
circulate every year they account for
about 15 to 20
of the respiratory infections that come
into our hospital every year
um and an infection with one coronary
virus type if you will stereotype
does protect you against sort of
moderate to severe disease for a few
years so that's good
um but you know it's it's not um we're
not going to
uh eliminate this virus with so-called
natural occurred immunity which you've
heard sometimes from the administration
that just let's get it let's
everybody get sick then they'll get hurt
immunity and then we won't have to watch
this this uh virus circulate anymore
that's never happened for any infectious
disease i mean we eliminated smallpox
because we had a vaccine
we eliminated measles from this country
in 2000 because we had a vaccine
natural infection will never provide
enough herd immunity to eliminate the
virus um
yeah i mean it's a misnomer in a way
because you need the vaccine to create
hurt immunity but the people have
conveniently skipped over that um we're
going to jump to
paul josh v how do vaccines work
can you give a vaccine 101 explainer
perhaps
a vaccine science for dummies sort of
thing
can i just say right up front the public
confidence right now in the cobie
response isn't great so let's not use
phrases like
vaccine for dummies it's going to really
freak people out so
but go ahead yeah so i i'd enjoy this as
well so vaccine 101.
so the goal of a vaccine is to induce
the protective immune response that is a
consequence of natural infection
without having the person pay the price
of natural infection
so you want the immunity without having
to have the severe symptoms
that's how you make every vaccine and
you
and and why does it take 20 years
well you have to sort of do things
sequentially so so normally what you do
is so-called pre-clinical trials and
experimental animals you find for
example syrian hamsters get you know
when you inoculate the messiah's cov2
virus develops symptoms
similar to people then then you they use
have an idea for a vaccine i'm going to
take the virus and activate it with a
chemical
so that it can't reproduce itself so
that it can't cause disease but
hopefully it can still induce an immune
response and see if that works to
prevent
protect this little syrian hamster from
getting infection and then you do
it in a lot of hamsters or a lot of mice
or rats or ferrets or monkeys
um and then you so that's your proof of
concept now you know this way
the strategy you have for making a
vaccine might work plus
you get to really literally dissect out
that part of the immune response
in the animal that seems to be protected
okay so now you think you have your
vaccine so now you do phase one studies
just be clear so a vaccine is a way of
tricking your body into thinking it had
the disease
prefer not to use the term trick on the
anti-vaccine people
love that term okay it's a natural way
of doing it you're eating these things
naturally it convinces your body that it
had the disease
that's a lawyer it's basically like a
lawyer like a personal injury lawyer
trying to convince you
to settle uh the wuhan
no he's still going he's still going
okay so i'll go quickly so then you go
to phase one studies which usually
twenty to a hundred people so-called
dose-ranging trials you try and see what
dose of that vaccine you want to use
then you go to phase two studies
which are hundreds of people to make
sure that your vaccine is consistently
safe and induces an immune response then
you go to phase three studies which are
tens of thousands of people who either
get a vaccine or don't get a vaccine
that's the only way you can show that it
works then you may have to produce it
which so as you go from from each of
those steps you go from hundreds of
thousands of dollars to pre-clinical
studies
to millions to tens of millions to
hundreds of millions of dollars and then
you mass produce it which is hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars
what's happened here
is that essentially the government and
other agencies have taken the risk out
of it for pharmaceutical companies
they've said
we'll pay for the phase free trials
we'll pay to mass produce it at risk
meaning we'll mass produce it without
even knowing whether it works
or knowing whether it's safe and then if
it doesn't work and it's not safe we'll
throw all these
these millions of doses away no company
would ever do that
so that's that's why it's so fast that's
part of the fast tracking i get it
do you really trust that the vaccine's
going to come i
know it's not going to come by the
october as some politicians have said
whatever but like
it seems awfully convenient that the
world is in a pandemic and we're all
sort of freaking out and for the first
time ever
the pharmaceutical industry is able to
generate a vaccine quickly
does it feels a little too convenient or
coincidental or am i just
uh a negative pessimist
you're you're a negative person he's on
and he's on the moon
yeah exactly you know when you're on the
move it's very lonely
the rare the rarefied atmosphere yeah i
think
you're right i mean if you look at the
phrasing the language that surrounds all
this warp speed
race for vaccine finalists um it's scary
and and
we've never made a vaccine the fastest
vaccine previous to this was was the
mumps vaccine which took four years to
develop
so so it's scary that it says but i will
say this
as long as we do the phase three trial
the big phase three trial this 30
000 plus person phase three trial where
you see whether
tens of thousands of people get the
vaccine tens of thousands don't get the
vaccine
and to see whether it works that's
typical for a vaccine trial
uh you know the hpv human papilloma
virus vaccine that was a 30 000 person
trial
the pneumococcal vaccine was a thirty
five thousand first draw so this is
typical so if we just let it go to
completion then then i think we're good
that's the
that's the proof okay and this and this
this responded to two questions that
were similar
just from patreon uh about uh how do you
how does it how do you fight bad side
effects of uh
of uh of a vaccine and uh also a person
asked is it really realistic quickly by
the end of the year so
uh it did address a couple of questions
so let me move on leslie we got to take
a quick break
and when we come back we'll pick up more
cosmic queries
for dr paul offit vaccine specialist
in philadelphia we'll be right back
we're back on star talk cosmic queries
vaccine
edition got dr paul offit here uh thanks
for taking time
out of what i know is a busy schedule uh
to
to offer your expertise to our fan base
and our broader audience
so uh paul you've got some questions for
us i do these are
from patreon folks this is leslie
goodwill my daughter trinity asks
if a covid19 vaccine will reduce the
numbers of
anti-vaxxers meaning as they might see
firsthand the benefits
of vaccines and i don't know to me what
definitely will change the minds of
anti-vaxxers
is dying from the disease maybe that
would help change somebody's mind like
yeah
it's a darwinian solution to that
problem yeah so paul is
is are people just missing their daily
miracle science miracle and this is why
do you have any sense of
what's driving this what's the anti-vaxx
movement yeah so well
the anti-vaccine movement's been around
since the first vaccine since the
smallpox vaccine in the late 1700s
i think i think at the heart of it is um
i i guess i divide it into two groups i
i think one group in the most common
group and this is okay or people who are
vaccine skeptics
um they're concerned about whether or
not the vaccine is safe and effective
that's fine i mean i think i'm a vaccine
skeptic i'm on the fda vaccine advisory
committee
i think everybody that sits around that
table is a vaccine skeptic we want to
see the data
i think the the true anti-vaccine
activist is really a vaccine cynic i
mean they think that pharmaceutical
companies control everything
it doesn't matter what the data are they
know the truth they know that bill gates
started all this they know that the
virus is transmitted through the 5g
network they know that influenza vaccine
actually has sars cov2 in it
they know all those things and there's
no talking them out of it so i don't
think anything will convince them of
anything other than vaccines are always
bad
um how about just saying to them
have any of your friends recently called
in to work sick with smallpox
how about how about that
that's a pretty convincing one who was
it that said you can't use
reason to argue someone out of a
position they didn't
get into by using reason that's a good
point yeah you know that's uh
that's one of the great challenges so uh
dr often i didn't i didn't hadn't
thought about it these two separate
camps
and so it seems to me if you could
convince people who are skeptics
that will take us quite a long way and
the rest are just
you're not going to get them no matter
what yeah i think reason and logic works
for people who are reasonable and
logical
you just have to find a way to and you
do this better than anybody to convert
you know some difficult scientific uh
issues and try and make it
understandable and to present it in a
compassionate and passionate and
compelling way
and i think people are convinced as long
as data can convince them
stevenson when he was running for i
guess it was president um
and you know he's an intellectual right
and he and
that's the quote goes something like he
says but i
i have the vote of every uh thinking
person in the country
and his his team said but sir you need a
majority
but but but a cynic on vaccine is doing
the same thing in a way as people who
won't wear masks
they're putting others at risk by
refusing to protect themselves right so
there's again going back to this sort of
social responsibility and ethics
question that
you can't seem to get around am i right
exactly right
you're not making a decision for
yourself only if you want to die from
tsar's code v2
that's your decision but the the point
is you're pulling down other people with
you
okay uh this is uh also from patreon
rude vander linden
do we already have an idea of what
people will be vacs what people will be
vaccinated
first will it be the most vulnerable or
will it be specific groups
that have the potential to be super
spreaders is there any strategy for this
and who will be responsible for
executing
the strategy that's a brilliant social
question yeah
right so there are two groups that make
this decision one is the so-called
advisory committee for immunization
practices which advises the centers for
disease control and prevention or cdc
and the other is the national academy of
medicine
both of them are in the i've been
putting out actually who will be that
first tier
of people who will get this vaccine so
the answer to the question is it's both
it's both people who are vulnerable
specifically those greater than or equal
to 65
people who have certain comorbidities
like you know chronic lung disease
asthma
obesity and other comorbidities and then
people who are on the front lines
essential workers
health care workers teachers people who
work in in say in law enforcement etc
so actually if you look at the numbers
that were generated by the the uh the
cdc
it's about half of the american
population american adult population
children will not be
on the front line initially of getting
these vaccines um
so it's you're talking about 150 million
people to what is likely to receive
to be a two dose vaccine that's 300
million doses that we would have to get
out there
for a two dose vaccine that has to be
separated by about a month it's going to
be
very difficult to to do that yeah but
it's it's it's
it's a uh i don't want to call it a dry
run because it's a real run but if it's
something that we're going to have to do
more in the future
we might as well work on getting it
right this time
agreed and i think i think we'll learn
as we go i think also people will feel
better
because not everybody's going to get the
vaccine initially initially it'll be 500
000 people then a million then 2 million
and as you see that it's safe
now in that many people as compared to
say the 20 000 that were studied uh
pre-approval i think people will be more
and more comfortable with the
why why are two doses needed
um it's just it's it's that's what's
required to induce immune response that
we think
is what works we don't know that yet i
mean the the phase three trials have not
been completed we don't know any whether
any of these vaccines work so the second
shot
the second shot would be the same uh
the same uh vaccine and amount as the
first one or is it sort of
one has to build on the other it boosts
the first one the only example
of a vaccine where it's actually a
different virus from the first first
shot then a month later the second shot
is the russian vaccine actually
okay um okay by the way and i know this
is your area doctor but i
have personal knowledge that the people
who are going to get it first are lebron
james
um anybody that gets the board first
class and not and uh
you know the kardashians because they're
not going to sit in a parking lot in the
car and just waits for someone to come
so you figure that out yeah exactly
moving on to
gordon vu uh uh do you think cover 19
will linger on even though we have
developed vaccines something similar to
flu
so so flu's different i mean flu mutates
so much from one year to the next
it changes its surface coat so much from
one year to the next that natural
infection or immunization the previous
year doesn't protect you so we need to
give a yearly vaccine
i don't think that's going to be this
virus i mean this virus has only been
out there for about 10 months or so so
it's hard to know exactly and although
it does
mutate all viruses like this so-called
single-stranded rna viruses
mutate a little it doesn't appear to
functionally mutate in a way that
suggests it's going to evade the vaccine
at least not yet
so i think we can i think we can make a
vaccine that can protect us for a few
years
i think if we're still willing to to
wear mass and do hygienic measures which
we're going to have to do
we're going to have to do both things i
think people are going to think well
i've gotten the vaccine i can don't have
to worry about a mask
but if a vaccine is 75 effective which i
think everybody would be happy with
that means that one out of every four
people isn't protected against moderate
to severe disease
probably a greater percentage of that
still could shed virus and be contagious
with you know mild symptoms or
asymptomatic
so i think we're still going to need to
wear a mask and it's
it's been hard because obviously that's
not the administration's message the
administration's message
is the opposite of that i mean donald
trump does everything he can to try and
discourage people from wearing masks
it's really hard to watch
because that's the more powerful of the
two i mean i was on service last week at
children's hospital philadelphia walking
around the words
if you and and came in contact with
people if you ask me which of the two i
would prefer
a vaccine or a mask mask i mean that's
that's much more likely to be effective
than the vaccine
a quick herd immunity question so if you
have people who are rejecting masks
and they're walking around and and
they're rejecting vaccine
and then everyone else gets vaccinated
then
and they don't get sick because
everybody else got vaccinated and
everybody else wore masks
they would just say see none of that was
necessary because now no one is left to
make them sick
so this this could this could interfere
with people's rational
analysis of what had just happened it's
like saying you don't need you don't
need dandruff shampoo you don't have
dandruff
it's the same meanwhile it looks like he
came in from a snowstorm right
no it's just a writer right you're a
free writer the free writer right yeah
and so i think
it's so i think we can eliminate this
virus from the united states and usually
when you talk about what percentage of
people need to be
immunized in order to eliminate it
depends on two things the contagiousness
of the virus
and the effectiveness of the vaccine if
this vaccine was 75
effective you'd probably need to
vaccinate about two-thirds of the
american population to stop spread
roughly okay so people can still live
within that
they'll just free ride on everybody else
all right
again in a free country if that's what
you're going to do okay so
paul you got another one i do i have by
the way paul just so you know i'm
calling you paul
i'm going to call our good doctor dr
offit so i'm going to call you
or you could call me paulie which is
what everybody in my family calls
is that right okay that's why i will
just distinguish the two of you all
right paulie
yeah paulie two shoes that's my name um
everyone is talking about rushing a
vaccine which means there will be risks
given that copenhagen is way less severe
on young people than older people would
it be possible
for young people the risk of vaccine
that is not fully
uh tested is higher than the risk of
getting it getting covert 19. uh
so i think they're saying you know test
it on young people first in a way
that must be an old person who who said
that
it's a fair question i mean it's always
a matter of risk benefit if you're a
healthy young person you are
unlikely to die from this infection
there was just an article that was
published in something called morbidity
immortality weekly report just yesterday
which looked at of the 109 that's a
publication with that title
are you serious oh my god
wow wow little a little light reading at
night before you go to bed
just from your stuff you guys are
missing it you know yeah
okay i'm sorry to interrupt go on what
it did look at the
people morbidity and more more
it's a great beach reading it's great
beach reading sorry
sorry okay continue dr off it continue
um the uh yeah so what they did was they
looked at this they looked and more
almost 200 000 people have died from
this virus
of the the number of people who have
died who are less than 21 years of age
even though they make up 26
of the population is only point 0.08
so you're right you're much less likely
to die if you're a healthy young person
um and so therefore it does have to be
held to a high standard i think it has
to be very clear that this virus is safe
in in that age group before
uh you can reasonably give it to them
because you're right there
the risk benefit ratio is different i
mean for somebody like me who's
obviously a very
very very old person um you know for me
based on what you're reading it's pretty
clear that that's your very
i think so the risk benefit ratio really
does depend on what your risk is of
getting the disease and
so then the those ratios change so just
i just understand your number you said
oh sorry that age group is 25
of the population but what percent of
the cases are they well of the deaths
it's 0.08 of cases it's about 380 000
cases in
what it what's prob reported cases but i
think it's probably a tenth of what it
actually is
all right so so they're particularly
deadly to old people
if they can be cavalier about possibly
getting it
but they'll then be carriers and
spreaders of it
yeah you certainly can spread the virus
asymptomatically that's that's what's
the surprise that's the scary part
yeah yeah so therefore everybody's pr
everybody everybody sees a problem
i got it my son got it i had symptoms my
son had barely any and
that's that's generally true children
get it generally less frequently and
less severely good
now we're scared of everybody we see on
the street right because anybody could
carry this virus it's made for
strange time just a quick follow-up
question relating to kids for small
children i don't mean that like
literally you know nine years old eight
years old
is there some special protocol in
addition to what they would normally do
with vaccines
given that they're children do they take
greater precautions do they have to be
prepped more i i don't know what the
term is but
so um this is not a vaccine that's
initially going to be given to children
all the trials that are being done in
the united states are not done in people
less than 18 years of age i mean i
worked on a vaccine rotavirus would that
virus
cause fever and vomiting and diarrhea
and dehydration and death in
young children babies usually less than
two years of age so therefore the
studies were all done in babies i mean
our trial was a 70
000 person baby trial you know that took
four years and
was in 11 countries and and was a
massive trial
so that's what you do i mean if you're
worried about the disease in children
you test it in children
so what's going to happen here because i
think people will want to vaccinate
children down the road
i think these vaccines will be approved
then they'll get out there
and then they'll be tested in children
because you can't really give it to
children unless you test it you have to
make sure that at some level it's safe
and effective before you put it into
children
and so i just think that's all going to
happen after these vaccines are approved
okay related to this
uh john paul we gotta take another our
last break uh before we go to our third
and final segment
and we're talking about vaccines in the
coronavirus
pandemic on star talk cosmic queries
we'll be right back
we're back star talk we're talking about
vaccines
in this modern pandemic of
covet 19. i got dr paul off it i don't
know is he
the man the man on town on the town was
gonna fix all of this
is that right or at least tell us how to
get through it
uh thanks for being here as our uh
in-house expert for these cosmic queries
paulie you got some more questions for
us yeah we were talking about uh before
the break we were talking about kids
and and the effect of this on them in
the vaccine related to that john
jacobson
uh have there been investigations which
strongly suggest that young people are
perpetuating the spread
by their greater socializing if this is
true how do we convince young people to
change their behavior
to continue their ability to benefit the
world society
i mean i think you argue with them until
they're blue in the face then tell them
that that they're thick-headed and that
they ruined thanksgiving
you know you're the thing you say to
every kid the usual the usual yeah
uh you know so what are your what are
your tactics yeah i mean because kids
feel
you know they're risk they're risk-free
right like they
nothing i mean you know that some kids
are breaking their necks doing keg
stands in college right but it's sort of
like
hey you know so how do you get through
that risk-averse
point of view beats me i mean if you if
you look at what happens on college
campuses
you know they they they want to have
on-site
uh learning which makes sense but you
know you can't ask these 18 to 22 year
olds to be something other than 18 to 22
year olds they're going to have parties
they're going to drink they're going to
have on-site or off-site or off-campus
parties and
and to convince them to try and convince
them that they're at risk and they are
at risk i mean it's it's uh
you know it's certainly not risk-free
this virus is is can be
fatal even in a young person but but
these are people who have an age where
they believe they're invulnerable you're
not going to convince them of that so
i think if you're going to have them be
back on campus realize there's going to
be a certain amount of disease
um and and this is the whole problem in
general
is if we want to avoid this virus if you
want to avoid catching it or dying from
it then stay inside for the next two
years i think that's that's the answer
if
you're going to walk outside then
realize you're taking a risk so i think
what we have to do
in any situation whether it's elementary
school or college or
middle school is we have to figure out
the best way to mitigate the risk
especially for those who are at highest
risk like the teachers
who are older and and realize there's
going to be some spread and there's
going to be you know there may even be
some death and and
you know but the other side of this
pandemic that nobody talks about
as much is that the the the is that it's
led
to massive joblessness which has led to
massive homelessness which has led to
all the
the problems of homelessness like food
insecurity and depression and suicide
and child abuse and domestic violence i
mean that's the other part of it so we
do need to find a way to get back
to work our country is so bad at this it
is hard to watch
other countries have been able to do
that they've been able to revive their
economy they've been able to get back to
work they've been able to get back to
school
here we have roughly four percent of the
world's population and 25
of the world's deaths it is
unconscionable we are a technologically
advanced society
with economic advantages and we just are
tr our han
our way of handling this is to say to
basically try and deny it
or hope there's some magical way of
making it go away like you know the uh
oleander extracts or you know your uv
light or
clorox or whatever it's just painful to
watch but but
how do you really feel though we're not
really sure
you gotta stop mincing words yeah yeah
it's just it's just well listen i mean
if
you know i think the vaccine is gonna
take a while because you know it sounds
like it i mean
maybe because these maybe is it the
researchers are working from home and
nobody gets anything done working from
home right
you got to play with the kids you end up
down an internet rabbit hole the next
thing you know
yeah youtube a youtube
uh right yeah and you're you know at
home depot buying a circular saw that
you really don't need
you know that's you know um this is an
interesting question and it's
a little silly but this is interesting
to me and i think there's something
a point of view here that's pretty
strong this is a k
profit 2032 patreon if is a vaccine even
necessary
when you look at the actual mortality
rate of the disease
to me that feels like someone that
doesn't believe in vaccines or whatever
but
but anyway if we want to really
eliminate this virus from the face of
the earth and we can
his history teaches us that the only way
that's going to happen was with a
vaccine
we did it with smallpox we've done it
with two out of three strains of polio
we can do it with measles we have done
it with measles in the united states at
least until 2000.
um that's it that herd immunity from
natural infection is not going to do it
masking alone is not a long-term
solution so i think the combination of
masking and social distancing and hand
washing
and along with vaccines is our way out
of this
but it we're not going to get out of
this without a vaccine
so you mentioned earlier all the
collateral damage that doesn't get
talked about as much
as the direct cases of the virus like
you said the loss of jobs and the
homelessness and
domestic violence and the like so that's
the total cost
of the pandemic right it's not just the
medical cost
it's the rest of its what it has
inflicted if you will
on society but but going forward
what we wanted we we just don't want
this to happen again
so are you really telling me you can't
you can't have a shelf of serums a shelf
of vaccines
ready on the in the wings for anything
that comes up
that handles classes of viruses
all right our virus is so diverse that
they
they defy your ability to have a serum
that takes out
whole categories of them and so specific
right like
every virus has its own animal so to
speak right
i think you can do this i think you can
have a worldwide surveillance system
when the minute something like this pops
up
that you that the world knows about it
then you have the virus in hand but but
i think
in terms of how to best make a vaccine
is really pathogen-dependent i mean what
we've chosen to do here
is we've chosen the vaccines that
frankly are the easiest to construct
the fastest to construct and the easiest
to scale up that's that's
that that's how that choice was made
this so-called plug-and-play vaccine is
genetic vaccines i mean you know that
you know what you're interested in you
know the protein of the virus you're
interested in
it's that spike protein that emanates
from the surface of the virus it gives
it
its name it makes it look like a crown
corona so that's that's the protein that
attaches viruses to cells if you can
prevent the virus from attaching to
cells
you can prevent the virus from infecting
cells i.e infecting you
so you know you know the protein you're
interested in you know the gene that
makes that protein
so all these these strategies messenger
rna dna
so-called replication defective
adenoviruses or simian adenoviruses
are all based on that just just take the
gene plug it in
and give the vaccine now that just
because they're the fastest to make
doesn't mean they're going to be the
last best vaccine
i suspect two or three years from now
we're going to find there's a better
vaccine out there
but but that's how this was all
constructed so in other words like do
you develop a short-term vaccine because
it's
a quick fix and simultaneously or
then you go to find something that has a
longer lasting effect
well hopefully these vaccines will be
great see the problem with this is that
we don't know anything about these
vaccines message rna dna
replication defective antiviruses there
is no commercial
equivalent for those vaccines so so this
is new territory
so basically you're taking a new virus
the bad coronavirus that's already had a
number of surprising clinical and
pathological manifestations
and you're going to meet that with
vaccine strategies that have never been
used to make a vaccine before
what could possibly go wrong right so
what you're saying is
that's why some of the early attempts at
vaccines or
or or cures were things that had been
already fda approved for other
purposes and then because then that
would speed it to
to implementation if that worked for you
well we could so so for example the
chinese have an inactivated
sardis cov2 vaccine take the virus grow
it up kill it with formaldehyde we have
those kinds of vaccines the inactivated
polio vaccine is that the hepatitis a
vaccine is that
the rabies vaccine is that so you always
feel comfortable with those strategies
because you you have a long
history with those kinds of strategies
um but you know the ones that are
currently going to be coming out first
you don't have as much history from
which and so there'll be a learning
curve here i think over the next few
years i'm sure there's things
that we're going to learn in the next
few years that we wish we knew now we
just have to be open-minded to that and
we also most importantly have to be
transparent with the public
about what we know and what we don't
know moving forward
again another question that we have
another one yeah a couple more couple
more john jacobson
uh if coven 19 vaccines cannot produce
sustained antibodies for a considerable
time in a person
are researchers concurrently
investigating another line of defense
or with virus mutation over time and or
herd immunity be our only hope
you don't always just need antibodies in
your circulation to
to neutralize the virus sometimes all
you need is so-called immunological
memory
meaning that you have so-called b and t
cells in your body that remember that
it's seen this this virus before
and then there's enough time when you
then confront the virus for those kinds
of memory cells to become activated
differentiate to antibody producing
cells that protect you so
i i do think that we can have a vaccine
that protects one for a few years
one two is i think this is a single
serotype virus this is not flu
i mean all the evidence so far is that
this is not flu meaning it's not going
to mutate
one year to the next although just don't
hold me to any prediction i make on this
show
[Laughter]
for everything that becomes wrong we
have to like flash up a date he said
this before we knew
exactly people be outside with the
sticks and stones outside your house
pitchforks pitchforks is this exactly
right universal sign
isn't the answer at this point magic
spells and chanting to get rid of this
thing
isn't that pretty much it i mean i think
you need sort of sock puppets and a
magic 8-ball
there you go there you go alex lopez
patreon
dr paul offit what is the effect
efficacy required for an upcoming
covet 19 vaccine for us to be able to
return to normal
or close to normal as possible
i think it's going to depend on what
level of disease and death we feel
comfortable with
again i mean it's last year for example
based on
[Laughter]
how much death do you want yeah we you
know who we have he's dr evil that's who
[Laughter]
so for example let me explain last year
we had 780 000
hospitalizations from influenza and 60
000 deaths
could we have prevented a lot of that
sure we could have prevented by wearing
mass and social distancing watch what
happens this year
this year as we enter the winter because
a lot of people still are wearing mass
in social disney we will have
one of the the least harmful flu seasons
in a long time
so there you have it we can we can
prevent the flu with hospitalizations
and deaths every winter if we want
by wearing mass and social distancing
more but we don't do that because we
sort of have grandfathered flu deaths
in as being okay i do think as as time
goes on with this virus
we are going to probably reach find that
there's a certain level of disease and
death
that where we feel we we're as a risk
we're willing to take
and go back to our normal lives see
doesn't sound like does that sound less
evil
a little less just a little less evil
i feel death all around me right now
i think the philosophers call that a
utilitarian approach
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
a couple more couple more phillip lyons
uh
this person seems skeptical they say is
there any possibility that vaccine could
be developed as fast as by the end of
the year doesn't this sort of thing take
years to prove effective and safe
so dr offit what's interesting about
that question is you could conceivably
develop a vaccine quickly but the trials
take so long
so what are the medical ethics
of saying i have a vaccine that could
save
tens of thousands of lives but we have
to test it
just to know and where do you draw that
line
in your panels that you're on and all
the rest you
have to test i know we're in the midst
of a pandemic i know a thousand people
are dying a day but you can't put a
vaccine out there
that may end up not being effective and
then have people think that it's
effective you can't put a vaccine out
there that that might be safe and find
out that it's not safe because then
you've taken an already
scared american public and scared them
more and possibly lost any chance you
have of doing a vaccine i'll give you
another example
polio i am old enough to remember polio
i
mean
when polio would cause 30 000 people to
be children
children to be paralyzed every year it
would cost 1500 children to die every
year
yet before and so jonas tried to make a
vaccine he
he took the virus and activated it he
tested it in 700 children in the
pittsburgh area
it induced a great immune response it
was safe he could have said this is it
let's put it out there but instead we
did a one-year
prospective placebo-controlled trial of
620
000 children actually to prove that the
vaccine was safe and effective and if
you think people
were any less scared by polio then than
they are sargeras cov2 now
then that's because you're young because
it was it was that was a devastating
disease then i mean my parents were
scared to death of that virus and
in terms of we wouldn't let us go to
public swimming pools it was it did
change people's lives
but we were willing to wait then and we
can wait now and it's not that big of a
wait it's really
months long wait um
we have one more if you want to do one
more yeah let's do that one one more and
then we got it
we gotta call it quits all right nika
schartzvilli
sorry uh i'm doing the best i can uh
how do scientists actually test the
vaccine to avoid any bad side effects
now we've you've talked about testing
but to add on to that
so what if what side effects are
acceptable
what are not acceptable yeah great
question who makes those who makes those
decisions
ultimately the public makes those
decisions i mean we we
you in this pre-licensure trials that
have been done so far the so-called
phase one studies these viruses these
vaccines do cause fever
including high fever and then the
symptoms associated with fever headache
chills muscle ache i mean in a certain
percentage of people in one one trial as
high as 50
of people is that is that a level of
side effects that you're willing to
accept
for this virus i think most people would
say yes um it's it's basically a level
of side effects we accepted a single
vaccine
i mean the shingles vaccine you know
causes that same sort of level of fever
and uh and you know muscle legs etc but
you know to avoid shingles which is one
of the worst pains of medicine people
are willing to do now you could argue
since i saw you shaking your head um
that you know as a helper don't pay
attention he's on the moon
why are you even i'm not don't i don't
none of this affects me dr offer don't
feed the trolls
okay um yeah
i mean i think most people would accept
that as a side effect fever as an
occasional side effect because
this is a scary virus and if it means
they get to go back to work and
live their normal lives again then then
it's worth it so we'll see
but i think what they wouldn't accept is
they wouldn't accept any severe side
effect that caused a permanent harm
naming or some other kind of permanent
so let me
we got to end it but i got to ask you
one thing uh
paul not paulie paul uh
in my field and in so many other fields
uh computers
uh simulations modeling has replaced
actual sort of physical testing on live
subjects or on
in real situations we we can now
simulate
what it is to fly in an f-18
fighter jet okay why is
medicine not there yet with being able
to
to simulate and test the effects of a
vaccine
on human physiology so that you don't
have to run through all these trials
you load up you have you got people's
genome uh
just can't you like shake and bake that
and run a million
simulations and say this will get
headaches and this will get that that's
good let's go to
let's go to production um
because historically there's always been
surprises i mean i guess i'll give my
personal experience um
you know i worked on a virus called
rotavirus which is a cause of fever
vomiting and diarrhea and kills about
2000 before the vaccine came out kills 2
000 children a day in the world
so when i came into that that that uh
that um
that virus when i came to first start
working on that virus that field
um it was the early 1980s um at that
time the virus had been studied for
40 years it was known to be an animal
pathogen it was known to be a human
pathogen by the time the first vaccine
came out which was not the one i worked
on or we worked on but it came out in
the late 90s so that virus at that point
had been studied for 60 years
and what that vaccine did was it caused
intestinal blockage
which was a serious and it can be an
occasionally fatal problem the disease
called into susception when your small
intestine kind of
telescopes into itself and then gets
stuck see how i work telescope into this
body
i noticed i noticed i got you on that
one
um and it was so you're 60 years into
this i mean and this
was a complete surprise it was
completely unpredictable and i just
think that's the history really of
of modern medicine i don't think there's
been a breakthrough that hasn't been
associated with a human cost
i think we just invariably learn as we
go you'd like to think we could
predict it but but we just often don't
yeah
yeah i mean there's no viruses in the
star trek universe they're in the 23rd
century
so we'll we'll look back on this
conversation look how primitive that
conversation was
look at look at how quaint they were oh
they're wearing masks
although i gotta get that morbidity
magazine that looks great
i gotta get me one of those available at
newsstands near you
we've gotta call it we gotta call it
chris there dr paul offit um
i i've known your work i was delighted
that you agreed to be
our guest on star talk uh and i hear
you're a fan of
the stuff i do too so thank you for that
as well
and uh paul mercurio good to have you
man oh
always fun great time all right all
right come come again on that all right
this has been star talk cosmic query the
vaccine edition
i'm neil degrasse tyson bidding
you